extranjero,
están las escaleras que suben a la
cabina de seguridad,
sí, no queda nada,
no hay palabras que puedan expresar lo que está pasando en
mi cabeza
y mis pensamientos, simplemente una
devastación total
[Música]
extranjero,
los incendios forestales de esta temporada no tienen
precedentes en Alberta en este
momento.  tuvimos un clima muy caluroso y
vientos impredecibles de alta velocidad, así
como una primavera muy seca, en todas esas
condiciones hemos llegado a un punto en el que
tenemos más de cien incendios forestales que
arden actualmente en Alberta
[Música],
en este momento tenemos más de 60  Bomberos,
dos helicópteros en el área enfocándose en
este incendio, arrojando puntos calientes sobre
puntos calientes y lo que estamos tratando de hacer es
minimizar el crecimiento del fuego y trabajar
desde afuera. Estos equipos están cansados.
Necesitamos nuevos recursos para este incendio.
[Música]